hi everybody welcome to free code camp i
am sam
from python basics and this video we are
going to be looking at the
td ameritrade apis and
we are going to be going from start to
finish
dropping in some pandas
it has everything json objects
how to dig into and build your own stock
screener
so what what is an api
an api is an application programming
interface
so basically what that means is all
right
we know you are going to want
information from us
we're going to control how you get that
information we're going to make it a
little bit easier
and then we're going to get it to you
and we'll go through all these steps
so first off i think i've
made this a little challenging so behind
me so for you
the register is going to be where you're
going to want to start
and also it's developer.td
ameritrade.com fill this in and of
course then after you do it
the login is right beside there
so i'm going to go ahead and
actually we can even look at this
so this is getting started so first you
have to create an account
then what you're going to do is you're
going to create an
app and we'll just uh
just so my apps
so i'm going to go ahead and log in
all right here we are getting started
creating a developer account
then new apps
so right here when you go to
my apps there's going to be add a button
and you just name it
the only thing that is very important
right here is the callback you can just
do the
http local host colon
8000 and that's all you need
not anything fancy so
we get that set up and the verification
process
goes uh very quickly so if you saw that
right there
new app when you get to this place and
here
is mine and there's going to be a little
bit
a couple of blurred things out here but
this is going to be your
key right here and we're going to go
through
all of this
and we have that set up yes right here
http localhost 8000
i'll have that down in the description
below
if you're not quite sure if you've not
seen uh the django series and you have
no idea what this is referring
you can just copy this and place this in
here
so all right now
the apis that we're going to be working
with
are instruments
and this is
how this data is going to be returned
and we're going to go through all this
but right now this is just a little
warm up and then you can actually then
choose
and we'll go through all this type of
data i know this can be overwhelming
right now
but real quick video today and actually
tomorrow's video is going to be a
challenge video that is
a challenge that you'll run into
uh when we do this so and then we'll
pick back up
uh tomorrow and then the following week
and we'll just delve into this and we'll
go
slowly but surely like we always do and
today we're going to be looking at
all of the different apis that
the td trade uh td ameritrade
uh have to offer and also after that
we're going to have the answer for our
challenge
eight so if you're new here thanks for
joining us make sure you're hitting that
subscribe button
notification bell and if this type video
you like go ahead and hit that like
button for me and also make sure you
stay in tune until the end to watch
right here because uh over 800 videos
there's a good chance
that you may not have seen all of them
so all right let's just get into it
so the apis that ameritrade has for us
are uh pretty impressive
and after we get done i'll show you the
one that we're going to be using
next all right so accounts and trading
so i'm only going to be showing you
stock data but everything that i'm going
to be showing you you can
extrapolate out and use for
any of these and i was posed the reason
why i'm saying that specifically is i
was posed the question
am i going to be showing you how to make
a trading bot
no one i don't want to be liable for
anything like that but two i want you to
understand and see this and really kind
of get you interested
in investing not in
um trading so there we go
all right but here are the accounts uh
here are the apis of how to trade place
an order
cancel an order uh you have your
authentication
um token right there uh here's
here's the uh instruments and
most of these as you'll see especially
like
markets and i'll show you another way
you're going to have a single you're
going to have one for a single search
and then multiple searches
so you can have look at the multiple
markets because there are
many many markets around the globe not
just
the nyse and the nasdaq
then you have the movers which are
companies stocks that are moving making
big moves
in one day excuse me guys i'm sorry
and also i am going to have the solution
or a solution to our challenge 8
after we get done after i announce which
api we're going to be using
option chains so options are
a tool that you can buy and it locks you
in and gives you the
option to purchase a share at a certain
price
price history that's pretty explanatory
you can go back
in time and any length of time in any
interval
quotes of course then you can go and get
single quotes
multiple quotes then you have your
transaction history
user information and watch list so you
can then create
uh an actual lists of things that you
want to watch that you don't
then have to go and check every day this
is
very very handy and it can even go in
and do multiple accounts
so all right all right so the one that
we are going to be
begin using and interact with the most
is going to be our search
search instruments and we will in
each api has its own address
very very useful so now let's deal with
our challenge eight so there is a
limitation
to our queries it is a max
actually i found that 500 worked so i
don't know what the max is i think i
toyed around with it i think
600 fails so it's somewhere between uh
5 and 600 so 500 real easy
round number so let's just go ahead and
look
at our solution
so let's just say and then let me get my
notes
and so all right our dilemma was we have
5450
so we're going to start at 0 and
end and
end at 500 so we're going to cycle
through 500
so while end less than
x then
print start
end
hey is somebody in there okay good i
want to make sure it wasn't calvin
and then now here's the part
so all that would happen is right now i
would just
go and it would print 0 and 500
repeatedly
because i'm not changing so now after we
print it
this is this is the coolest one that i
think i remember so i'm going to
just reassign that i'm going to add my
to my endpoint i'm going to increment
or in place
all right so let's see how i did
all right so now i'm close
but i have a dilemma right here
so now i'm outside the loop
start equals end
then i'm going to minus
500 then my new end
is x and
print start and end
saboom so here i go
i have zero through 500 500 to a
thousand
thousand to 1500 so on all the way
through
to the end it is literally
that clean that simple and i will show
you how to
integrate this into our queries and
we're going to use
all of the tools that we've used so far
and it's
quite interesting and then we're going
to really delve into some very cool
stuff with pandas
and we're continuing our series with
the ameritrade api so
i said last video on this subject that
we're going to be using the instruments
so let's just go ahead and familiarize
ourselves with this
so if you're new here thanks for joining
us this is what we do we do micro videos
one video upon a time micro videos and
we build upon it so we are doing
our series on the ameritrade apis and we
are looking at
the one api that we are going to be
concentrating on so they search
instruments and the way that this api
works
is here's actually the web address
right here for it and the way that this
works is
you're going to pass
in your your key
oops here we go your key
then the symbol that you might be
interested in
we'll just do boston scientific and then
now
here is the way in which
you're going to look at it
so let's just peek over here
so for the bonds like this stocks
fundamental data
and then the the instrument search
so in the projection we're going to type
in
fundamental and then
oops i guess i spelled it wrong last
time
fundamental the actual returns the
fundamental data of a single
stock instrument and if we wanted to we
could pass in
a more than one but let's just go ahead
send this off and look back at it
so here we go here is
all of the information associated that
with this api returns
it returns the symbol and as you can go
through you can see all these tags
um and as if you look very carefully
this is a dictionary
so key value pairs
and it has a tremendous amount of data
and uh in a couple videos we're gonna
we're gonna touch on how the type of
information this is
and how to then begin to extract it and
then place this
into a pandas pandas data frame
and really start crunching this stuff
down
today we're going to be continuing our
series uh for
the ameritrade api i'm going to be kind
of branching a little bit off of it
so we're beginning to build and
uh our extend our knowledge and
understanding
and really our access so really what i
want to do today
is one so you don't have to have it
around don't
need to retype it copy it we're actually
going to talk about how to handle keys
so as you can see right here i have a
keys dot p
y and that is actually because i don't
want to have to blur and forget
and go through and scroll and keep my
key
guarded so you can't see it and it's
really a good practice
so from keys but if you're new here
thanks for joining us this is what we do
we do micro videos
one video upon another and
i actually have the key just
named ameritrade ameritrade
and as you can see right there
spider knew what i was doing and then
now the only error i have is saying
it's brought in but it's not used so now
i don't have to worry about
you guys seeing it i can place it in
where i need to use it and move on from
there
this is an outstanding actually it's
best practice
so you're going to have multiple places
that you're going to go
and you just place it in the same file
so you won't have to lose track
now like i've always said don't ever
delete anything
now you can start organizing these
things
at a time because you're gonna you're
gonna start spreading your wings out
and going places and using multiple apis
where you're going to have multiple keys
so now you store them all in one place
title it the
tool that it is and place it in your
keys.py
or whatever config
config py however you want to do it but
this is best practice and i thought this
was a perfect place
to add this into our toolbox so there we
go guys
so all right let's just go ahead and get
after it so if you're new here thanks
for joining us
this is what we do we do micro videos
so last video actually i guess two
videos ago we talked about
uh which api we're going to be using and
we're going to be using
the instruments
for multiple
for multiple tickers but today we're
just going to be
doing doing one right now because what
we're going to be focused on today
is the actual response
because we need to start unpacking that
so if you're new here thanks for joining
us this is what we do we do
micro videos we do one video
at a time and we build upon it so here
is
our dilemma symbol actually we'll leave
that
so all right here is our key right here
here's our address and this
is how it works
so we're just gonna do our
payload
then here's our dictionary that we're
going to be passing in
so our api key
then it's our ameritrade
and then come down
then our symbol
and we're just going to pass it let's
pass it google
yeah let's see did i do that right is
that google symbol yeah
all right then
and then wha how do we what were how do
we want it
how what kind of information we wanted
and i said we were going to load the
projection
we want that to be the fundamental
dementor and tell
all right all right so we're done with
this
so now
uh results and i just realized i have
left out because
we have left out a ton right here so
import
requests
all right and that's all we need right
now yep requests
so then
[Music]
requests dot
get then what are we going to use we're
going to use
our this is where we're going
and what are we going to what are our
params
and we're going to pass it payload
all right all right so now we need to
really look
at we haven't really delved into
what in the world comes back and ways in
which
to look at it so here's our response so
let's look at dur
on results okay
so what we're going to be looking at
today
is a json object
and this is how we're going to begin to
unpack this
so you can what we can see results
then dot what text
okay so that's that's that
so here it is as
as a string okay then
that's okay so then i got to go in and
get stuff
or i can turn this into
aha so now
i just get the
whole object so now i use a json
i pull the json object out
and i can go through and i know how to
unpack this dictionary right here
so i have a dictionary then a dictionary
inside that
and then here we go with the symbols so
and all of the information 52-week high
52-week low
p e ratio peg ratio which is
i am a huge believer in the peg ratio
and we'll
we'll break down the ones that i truly
believe
but there we go this is the building
block
of where we're going to go from here and
we're going to add
all of the things that
we've done before especially our loop of
how to handle 500
uh i can't remember we're doing that one
next or if we're doing
uh no next video we're going to be
handling
um something very interesting
it's going to become handy but we'll do
that later so there we go guys
please please please drop any comments
questions video requests
make sure you join that discord server i
don't if you're brand new here
i don't want you feeling alone
somebody's on over there at all times
uh i have an admin and a moderator we
are literally around the globe
so join up there somebody's always on
answering questions
so all right um here's our
main layout but we want to test
all of the ticker symbols so let's just
go ahead
and bring this in so if you're new here
thanks for joining us this is what we do
we do micro videos
um we break them down
one at a time and build upon them and
probably the reason why
i love that so much is
because that is one of the subscribers
ways to describe it so we have a pretty
large growing community
uh especially over on discord
um so if you are learning python
alone go ahead and join the
server and you will not be uh we have
usually somebody on over there
answering questions all the time so all
right
if you haven't seen before this uh
is also the this file is on my github
so you can go and grab it and pull it
down
let's see company list it's saying what
is it saying i'm not using it
oh all right i need to bring in
oops import pandas as
pd all right so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to bring
in this spreadsheet
and then what i want to do is i want to
then grab
only these symbols so we're going to do
this too symbols
if i can spell today
but i hope everybody is doing well all
right
so then in that in that
uh file there is a column named
symbol and we're just going to grab that
and then what we're going to do is i
only want the values
of that and then i want that put into a
list
so we are covering a lot of things right
now
that pandas can do for us so
i'm grabbing this and then i don't want
this put into
a pandas series
i only want the values and then i only
want
that to be put into
a a list and it's going to be assigned
then to
symbols so all right so now i have
where i'm going now let's throw in
all of this right here
all right
now we ran into a problem
last time where we
or i i had expressed that there is a
problem
where we can only screen
500 at a time i've learned
i don't know exactly what the number is
but i know 500 works
so we are just going to do that so
now we need to do this in a loop
and we've done this loop before so while
oh
yeah also let me get this around so we
need our starting point
equals zero our end
equals 500.
so whoa so while
now there was also a flaw in the way in
which i did this
we could do this one more time outside
the loop and print
but we're going to use this while start
is less than uh
and we also need to do len
of no we don't have it yeah
len of symbols
because what we're doing is here's our
list here's our list of symbols and
we're going to
then iterate through these
500 at a time so as long as start
is less than the end
we're going to do this one more time so
let's bring this
all over and then now we're going to
make a new one right here
tickers because this is going to change
so then we're going to symbols
then our start
through stop or excuse me end
and
[Music]
and we're going to change this right
here
to tickers
all right then when we get done we need
to then
increment up start is going to be now
end
and then end
end is going to be
500 larger than before
all right let's do that again so i know
i've just changed a lot so we brought in
our symbols this is all of the symbols
of
all of the nasdaq and all of the
nyse it's going to be 4 000 excuse me 5
456. all right so we also know that
there is a problem where
this api will only well it will at least
i don't know only it will at least
search for 500 at a time
so now we're going to check 500
at a time and
this is how we're going to do it we're
going to go through
now i think we're about at a good
stopping point right here and we'll pick
up on this
next video because i know i just dumped
a lot on you
so but right here we're going to iterate
through
and the reason why we chose start
is so we don't have to do a loop
because if we did end right here we
would then have to do this
one more time outside of this and i
don't want you to have
code here i remember the first time i
tried this
i ended up i had code here and then code
here
it's the same code but accomplishing the
same task
so then it dawned on me i could just
change start
from end because you can have your
endpoint be
larger than what are the choices you
just can't have the start be out of
index
i'll say that one more time you can have
your end out of index range
it won't care but you cannot have your
start
be out of index range so there is a nice
little tidbit
so there we go guys so where we left off
was we changed this over we brought in
all our tickers right here
we changed out our api
to multiple because before it was
google g-o-o-g but now we have this
where we've also i've also shared you
the pain
that i know we can check 500 at a time
so right now we are going to be looping
through these
in 500 we're going to increment we're
going to iterate
over our symbols
and it's going to be tickers and we're
going to be doing 500 at a time
now we need to then
capture this data and
go through it and then come back and
revisit it so
we're going to pickle these responses
and come back and touch them later so
we're going to do this
now then we kind of need to deal with
a couple of things so we're going to add
in
time because we're going to need to
pause this because if you have a
fast computer when you
we're going to grab time and use that
as our file name if you've seen how to
handle
changing multiple characters that's
actually where this came to be
and automating file names
that's also where this came to be these
uh this problem that i have
and then we're going to use regular
expression
if i can type correctly regular
expression
to change all of the problem characters
for that windows does not like to have
file names named
all at one time so all right so let's
just go ahead
and get at it
so we have our
results now we also looked
last time at how to look at
json coming back so we're going to take
our data
then it's going to be results
dot json all right
then then now we need to then
save this file so our file name
file name is equal to
time dot
so what this is going to do is it's
going to spit out
uh the time down to the second because
we don't want date
uh because that's not differential a
differential enough
and then if you have a very fast
computer it may have
this took me a while to realize why i
was missing data i was getting all these
back so we're actually going to pause
one second
in just a minute all right so let's do
that
then we need to add our pickle file dot
p k l and i just realized we also need
to bring in pickle
didn't do that yet so if you've not seen
and you don't not sure exactly what any
of these are
you can go back and search all of these
i've done videos on
every single thing nothing is new
here yet and actually i don't think
anything is going to be new
here at all we're just cramming it all
together so now
now we have all right
let's see where we are so we've got our
data
we've got our file name now to save you
a little bit of pain there's going to be
two things that windows is not going to
like
it's not going to like the space in
between the time and it's not going to
like the colon in between the 9
the time so we're going to change this
name
[Music]
equals re sub substitution
then space
then colon then close out
and we're going to replace it with
underscore
and what are we going to be replacing
file name there we go
so all right so there we go let's go
through this one more time
so our data then
that's our json object here's our
automated file
creation then
we need to replace the space and the
colon
in the file name because windows will
not like it
and then now now we're going to
create the file and then dump the data
in so here we go with
open file name
oops there we go
as oh no right
i'm gonna close that out
as file then pickle
dot dump not jump dump
data comma file
all right now
yeah file yes file all right so here we
go
let's just go ahead and get this running
and let me just show you as this occurs
we're going to be now having the files
show up
and come through oops
haha if you add two t's
it does not know what you're talking
about
all right so we need to fix this i did
not reference this import
pickle as pkl
sorry guys
hopefully that will be the last mistake
that i've done but
these are all the type of things that
you're going to make mistakes on
and you become very very proficient at
understanding the code this is why
typing
is so very very important so all right
oh man i meant to have these
sitting here and popping so boom this
worked out
i think but let's just also make sure
we do time dot
sleep just for one second i forgot to
have that in there
just in case i think i'm a little bit
slow today let's see
yeah i got i'm eating up a lot of ram so
let's just make sure i realized that we
didn't i think i lucked out
i got a lot of programs open so make
sure you're putting
sleep one second right here to make sure
that you're not going to have and miss
any
any file names because that is exactly
it as you can see right here
boom each second apart and if i were to
close some programs i got a lot of stuff
running right now
uh i could have missed some files but as
you can see
this is down to the second and that's
what you want because
you need all of the entire time or your
files will have the same
file name and we'll go and you'll have a
problem and you'll start losing data
so that is why time is very
handy now if you want to do more and you
want to come up with specific file names
and increment
that's great i wanted i
always go the easiest route and time was
the first thing that came to me
so there we go guys so where we left off
last time
is we had a bunch of
pickled files right here so now we need
to figure out how to
extract and merge all this information
here so if we really think about it
we need to find out what files we want
or we could
track the files that we are creating
right here or right
here and then we have our variable name
right here so we could do
something like this
as we as we create them
we could then add them to our files
list and just append
5 f name
the reason why is because then the next
step that we're going to do
is we need to look and see let's go
ahead and rerun
this we now need to see
how in the world we're going to pull
from all of this
stuff that we have and
how in the world are we going to use it
and you'll see that
yes it is a dictionary after we
grab it as a json but it's not the most
user-friendly dictionary that you may
have seen
before so i'm going to show you a little
template
so let's see len of results i think is
that's right len of its data
there we go so let's see
is this uh
all right
so let's grab the keys data let's see
you can see that
all right so here are all the keys so
let's just grab one of them
data
ugp i don't even recognize that ticker
symbol
all right so holy moly
okay so we have
inside this then we have our
fundamental then inside that
it then has a key of symbol
aha okay so we need to then unpack
the fundamental which all right so i
will show you then what we need to do
so then we need to we need to come down
here
so what we're going to do is then we're
going to throw this into a list
and then this has everything
and then we're going to throw this into
a data frame so we need to go
and grab we need to grab every single
we're going to go through each pickle
file
move everything over then throw it into
a data frame
and we're going to extract what we want
so what we're going to look for
is what i have found to be the most
telling of what the way that i look at
things is we're going to look at
we're going to pull the symbol the net
the profit margin for the quarter then
the pe
then the peg p e ratio peg ratio
and the 52 week high
so those are all keys so let's just see
how far we get in this
so now we're gonna make a new
list empty list data let's bring this up
here
and for file in
files
then with open and file
rb
as as file
i have written this one in a while then
we're going to call this info
and we're just going to use our keep our
pickle
kl dot load and everything that we have
done
is there is a video on each specific
thing that i am talking about that's why
these are
micro videos so alright so now
so now i'm going to pull all of my
tickers
because then i'm going to go through
because each file
has a key and i don't know exactly so
i'm going to pull these
all out so let's look at this to tickers
equals list info
then i'm going to go then i'm going to
make my points
of interest
and these are the keys that are here
see this is very specific symbols
then net here i'm going to copy all this
because i know i'm going to type this
wrong and yes you're correct i don't
like this
but all right i will have
this down in the description below for
you guys to look at
all right let's move that back over
points then
for ticker
and tickers
for point and points
ticker dot append
info now check this out i'm going to
throw in ticker
then this is always
fundamental because it's the first
layer let me make sure
i typed that right so i'm going to cheat
okay did not and then my point
gonna grab that out
then my data append
each tick all right
okay we did that in about seven and a
half minutes
so i'm going through
each each pickle file 500
500 symbols at a time of a returned
there we go of a returned
uh fundamental of all of these
market movers okay all of these market
datas right here so you may like can you
be
you might like different markers so then
you would have different points that was
why i decided to use the
the term the variable points you might
want to be looking at volume
i know i had a question uh not too many
days ago
about wanting to see change in volume
this has
average daily volume so i can show you
how to merge
and pull from different data frames
we'll be doing that very soon
but this is a great stopping point we
are now we are about to merge and just
dump this all
i wanted to do this right here ah one
last
super important thing so now i just
realized
so if you do not do this you will have
your system
overrun with
with files that just build up throughout
the day so now we need to throw out
throughout the day or weeks os
so as we go through it as we pull out
all the useful information
for us we will then delete that file
forgot that one last part so cool got
through all this
good okay so now like i said we have a
we have a list of lists with
this data right here it's going to look
just just like that
and it is literally this
this simple right here so now
we need to make our column
titles so we're going to call those
points
all right and then literally it is just
a we're just going to copy this
boom right here so this is what we're
going to call them this is what
the keys are in the
j json response but we're going to title
them symbol margin p
e peg and 52 52 high
so because we know what that is and then
literally it is this simple
let's just start and go from here so df
df results get this out of the way so
you can see
results mpd
data frame the f is capital just two
uh i always had a hard time with that
and up here
all the list of lists is
data then we drop in
i might have to stare at this i can't
spell column
columns and we get pass in points
close that out and
literally that is it
so let's run this and as we can see over
here
oops i need to be right here run this
and as that's going through we can
literally just see but this
this is this is one of the
neatest things that i have
seen that when i started learning to
program that
now because when i when i was doing it
as you can see they're just building
here
that before i would put in to my
computer
and have stuff come out on the screen
that was very cool now
that then it got to the point where i'm
now
having criterium and i'm going out and
i'm touching
another computer and it's sending back
information
and i'm in control of the information
that i'm getting
and when i saw that i was i thought i
was hooked before
when when all the all of these things uh
were happening but after
after this it was it was uh
no holds bar so then now we're going to
have these
as they were building so now they're
going to go through now we're running
through
each of them and placing them in
uh the list and they will start
now going away
boom there we go okay and it's literally
done
so now df results
and here i go so now we don't need that
so now we slide over
so to remind you the way that if you've
not seen any of the
pandas pandas series again try we'll try
not to take that personally you can go
and see
uh two playlists one one is a pandas and
one is a
pandas project but the way that this is
is there's my index here's how big
how this is this is a 52 89
5289 rows by five columns
and what that what this automatically
does is it prints out the head
and the tail of the data frame just so
you can get an idea
and we'll go from here uh we're going to
be looking at
how to slice a data frame
with a pandas series
and with multiple series so all right
let's just go ahead and jump into it
so if you're new here thanks for joining
us this is what we do
we do micro videos so as you can see
we're going through and we're pulling
down
our our pickle our pickle files
and then we're going to then go through
them and we're going to then be building
our data frame and
as you can see down here we've we've
dumped this
in so if you have not seen in these
other videos
there are nine of course and everything
that we've done
here before there's been a micro video
on but this is going to be something new
that we've done
so here's our standard that we have
uh i'm going to delete this so i have a
this is our standard i know how to now
slice with we got
data frame peg so now this
is going to be so i've gone from my
df results data frame which
has 5288
down to 450
so i've i've gotten rid of i've sorted
out
i've sliced out a pretty significant
amount
but the issue is is
i want to have a certain
range of margin
a certain range of pe a certain range of
peg
that i care about so
there is a way that i have
we've done a video on this and so we
know
and so we have the keyword the condition
and but now we also learned about the
bitwise
operator the and sign
so we have true and true so true
and false so this is the technique that
we're going to use
to create what i prefer
and what i have found over time is the
best
practice of how i sort so we'll just go
ahead
and look at this and it's going to look
something just like this
so i have my results so i'm going to do
df
boop i'm going to change this df
dot peg we're going to change this out
and then just like normal df
results and i'll show you how to do this
so then we open it up now these are
uh these are tuples okay
so df
results then we pass it in just like
this is how we're passing in our
multiple series so then
peg just it's it's these over here so
capital i have my peg capital and then
start then i have it i want i want the
peg ratio to be less than one
so to remind you what the peg ratio is
is it is the p e ratio divided by growth
so if you have a p e ratio of 12 but
you're growing at 12
times your peg ratio will be one so
you can have a high p e but
as long as you're growing at the same
rate you're basically
back at zero so that's why i like less
than one
so now and
and then so we'll do this and
then df results oops whoa
df results i don't know why i
capitalized that
so i want it between a range so i want
it
greater than zero but less than one
so then peg again
oops close that out and also
greater than zero sorry greater than
zero
close this out another and
then i want df
results
and then margin
then close this out and i want this to
be i want you to be making a substantial
amount
of uh margin so i have that as 20.
then another one the last one is
i think this is the last one yeah
and then i want
df
results and i want the pe
to be greater than 10
then i close this out then boom let's
see if i typed all this right
nope all right so we're just going to
copy this
and i'll show you
let's see
and i forgot some parentheses so all
right
i knew this was a long shot
all right so here all right
so yeah i didn't wrap so make sure each
one of these is wrapped
in a tuple and going forward so i think
that's what i forgot right
somewhere right there right there i
didn't close that that one out
so all right so peg less than one
and peg greater than zero and
margin greater than 20 and
pe greater than 10 so then now
let's check this out
boom 149
different companies that then i can
examine
are they healthy and then there's ways
that
i sort this out but this is a very good
starting point for you
so there we go guys and we're going to
be looking at two
ways to view large data frames so if
you're new here thanks for joining us
this is what we do we do micro videos uh
one video upon
another and we build upon it so all
right
so i'm going to show you one that
one way i like to do it so we can see
the
um the column names and then
i will show you another way that you
guys will probably like because you
won't need to remember the column names
but i have a very short term memory
and i like to be reminded so all right
so we're going to make a function and
basically it's going to be like a loop
oops sorry
i've been a little off today so i can
already feel that the typing is going to
go
so basically we're going to kind of do a
looping through but we're going to
change this as
the size of however large you have your
little
your little window right here so we're
going to go to our start
oops start
equals 0 then stop is basically going to
be
the size
then while stop
oops less than
length of
our df
peg
then i'm also going to show you show you
how to sort in place we've already done
sorting by columns but i'm going to show
you in place and how it's going to give
you
maybe a little bit of what's going to
look like an error
but it's not df
df
peg then we're going to go start
and then stop
close this out
then start oops
start becomes stop and
[Music]
stop is incremented by size
and we could have changed this to uh ooh
and i misspelled view and i haven't said
this in a while but
this is not a spelling channel and we
could have used start and only done that
once but
i've already committed to the stop so df
peg and then one more time
start
stop close and close
so all right let's run this and it has
another w
i i apologize everybody like i said been
a little off today
so all right as we're going through this
you can see
wrong one there we go they are starting
to build
and we are building our but yes if you
have are just joining
if this is your first video of the api
there are 10 previous or notes to
today's 10. today's 10
and well now i want to check
today's 11 and uh
we are now touching hey was it already
done
it's already done so now we have our so
we have our results
which is everything all
52 88 and then our s
our skimmed down are sliced
with all our conditions now it's today
it's 150 so
now now right now when you type this in
you only have
view let's see if 40 fit here
all right oh okay so it looks like so
the reason why i like this
so i could have made it a little bit
smaller the reason why i'm having this
done in groups is so because i made the
mistake one time where i go okay
that was the peg but right now this is
not sorted ooh
we didn't sort it yet so let's sort it
so we we do
uh df peg
then we're sorting by this is what we're
going to sort
this is the method sort value
then we're going to sort it by in
ascending order
by peg i want to know the lowest peg
now you're going to see this and it's
going to look like it's going to throw
throw an error ah it's values
i am so sorry everybody with all this
wonderful typing
so now i have it in ascending order and
then so now you don't have to rerun the
reason why i'm making a function out of
this is you can do this so you don't
have to run this script
you can toy with this and then now you
can go and view
dfpeg or if you wanted to do this and
you change
change your data frames you can add that
so this is why i like this so let's
let's change this to 35
and then now it fits right here so i
only have to remember
just a little bit then i have my
reminder of my columns and i come
through
now for those of you who have
exceptional memories
and do not need that reminder there is a
way
so we have as as we have
here we imported pandas
as pd so there is a function pd
dot set option
then we're going to be displaying all
the rows
so display
dot max underscore
rows so we want as many so
basically this is kind of arbitrary you
could set this to 10 000 but we know
there's only 150
so i'm going to type in 200 so boom
so now i'm saying every data frame that
i call right now
print print them 200 at a time
all right um
and then move on as as a head in the
tail
so this is going to encapsulate all of
them
and their data frame is yeah df
dot peg so now i have all
150 at one time
without any of the columns being
reprinted
so there we go guys two separate ways
to view very large data frames
we have one more thing to do we're going
to be looking at the
pandas data frame is in method
what this method is so
very cool let's just go ahead and see
so if you've heard about join
in uh sql i was about to type join so we
got
uh our data frame peg i forgot it's
still set
on all of them so we have
and then also we have our
all right let's clear this out
our data frame
all right okay good so what we're gonna
do is let's say
this information that i've screened is
proprietary and i don't want anybody to
know about it
but let's just say i'm making
a um
making a list and i have a newsletter
and i'm sending these out but i only
want to give you
the symbol the company name the sector
and the industry but right now my data
frame
only has the ticker and
then let's see what else did it have so
it has
the peg the pe the profit margin
and the 52-week high that's all our
original
data frame had or the one that we're
most interested in
and let's see yeah that's still there
but our df
so this is oh yeah because we have that
only doing 200 at a time
so this is where this is in
method comes to be so i want to pass you
this information i don't want you to
know
the other information so now i'm going
to take
since there is a similarity just like
our join
in sql we're going to use our symbol
our symbol uh column and our symbol
column
and that's how we're going to associate
and then
this data this data frame only
with this information will come out so
let's just go ahead
and do this so we need to
pull out
it needs to it takes it as a list
so df
symbols
equals dfpeg
symbol
close this out then i'm going to put
this into a list because like i said my
my uh it is in method
takes a list so now now i have
from my here df symbols
so boom here's my list of tickers
and then i'm going to pass this
into all right
then i'm going to pass it into this
and this is going to make a boolean
just like all of our other series so i
pass this
and once you do this a couple times it
makes sense
so now this is my my my df my data frame
is
my data frame that has my symbol
uh my company name my sector
and my industry and
that one was capital s capital s
y and v symbol
close this out is in
then i'm going to pass it the list and
we call that
df symbols this is just like
our index indexing just like this over
here
so it's a little odd at first when you
when you think about when you see it but
once once you do it a few times it makes
it makes a lot of sense so now new
i just have true and false so is it in
or is it not
so then then i pass
this
and here's my new series excuse me
data frame so then i'm going to pass
this boolean
just like if it's passing or failing
just like
this scenario just like here
equals in my my data my df my data frame
is my symbols
uh name sector industry
then i pass it new my boolean
so now companies
so now here i go
i should have changed that setting so
now
unbeknownst to the recipients they have
no idea
how i've come up with this list all they
know
is that this list is
highly qualified companies to
move up higher they don't know the
criterium
that is i keep that on my end and there
is no
no extra work i don't have to touch but
this is a perfect example
of how you would go through and use
that api to check for
um anything moving that is perfect
for what you deem is ideal for uh
perfect movers
if you're interested in um i know i've
gotten a question
on volume so you compare these two
databases
excuse me data frames to each other and
then you go
the is in and these data frames
act exactly like tables and you use
the is in to do your joins so there we
go guys